yeah it looked like you attention and
fucking Floyd was fixed what you think
is real 100% you want to watch again we
can why do you think was fix that - come
on do you watch it yeah I've seen some
bullshit no it was a guy who's a
legitimate 155-pound man who is fighting
intentionally crying and rolling around
on the ground due to fights at 1:26 it
doesn't make any sense never had a
professional boxing match how crazy
who's fighting against the greatest
boxer listen to what you're saying so
small intentions fixed intentions their
fucking poster boy yeah and like yeah
here's Floyd Mayweather dude I don't
think they thought he was gonna knock
him out really tensions a beast man I
mean he's nice but when it comes to I
have but when it comes to boxing I
understand that but they were really
thinking he could hit him
this was the thought was attention is
really a striking genius have you never
seen him so scowling McGregor well but
no no but it's different
the tension is faster it's smaller I
mean he moves like a lightning bolt and
in Japan the the fact that this kids
only like 18 or 19 years old crazy and
been fucking people up including
knocking out world muy Thai champions so
they threw him to the wolves real early
on ok let's watch this and tell me tell
me why you think this is fake I see a
dude who's so much smaller than Floyd
look out little he is way smaller he's
way smaller Floyd is not even necessary
he's not remotely nervous
this kid is uh I mean I remember Floyd
laughing yes no matter he do this to
Conor right this cookbook of course
Conor can knock him out this can knock
him out he supposed to be the next big
thing dude he's a great kickboxer but
he's not kickboxing he's boxing you're
not gonna outbox Floyd Mayweather when
you've never had a professional boxing
match at least I don't think he has he's
had a lot of kickboxing though and in
kickboxing he's fucking amazing but he's
also amazing against guys at 126 pounds
that's so 18 dude look how small he is
compared to Floyd Floyd Stinney and
Floyd look how easily Floyd blocks those
punches and he's not feeling any danger
so he's just tied to put it on this kid
he's walking him down
he's walking him down looking for an
opening this the first round
just sweet he waits boom he cracks him
why would you
him does he just down with Brack you
don't think back it up back it up watch
it up Jim back it up let's watch it
again dude he cracked him watch this
right there here goes let it roll from
here gets in this corner here with the
left hook to the temple you don't see
that left hook to the temple watch water
pink right there thank you he fucking
cracked a dude who's a legit 30 pounds
lighter than an temple and dropped it
how these watch the track you just
watched it dude out you it's a that is a
famous flying that is a full-on left
hook first of all there was a stumble in
there as well but he hit him see the
stumble after he got ride that's a tough
one see that it's not tough at all the
kid gets up he got wobbled they give him
a standing eight count he looks nervous
as fuck he looks over he's sticking up
man great her fucking crazy and now
Floyd moves in and the kids even trying
to fire back he's just not good enough
man Floyd standing right in front of him
with his fucking hands up the kids got
no chance he's much smaller no
experience against a guy as good as
Floyd and Floyd's walking him down with
his hand this is real man this is real
that kids trying to hurt him he just
can't do it he's fighting the best ever
and then BOOM God's on was real that
uppercut was not all of its real first
one they love you as you should know
we've all seen guys get hit with shit
that didn't look like much and they go
down we've all seen it you know we've
all seen guys get touched on the chin
and they fall down let out Floyd look at
this do you remember Travis looter
versus Marvin Eastman you know that a
lot of people said that was fixed though
like that's fake
no one gets hit with the punch like that
no no sometimes you're coming to a fight
compromised look this is a hundred
percent legit one two right on the
fucking head he falls down dude this is
a hundred percent of legit fight this
kid got fucked up by the best boxer of
all time there - 126 I mean none of this
made any sense in the first place yeah
no sense but you gotta admit that's a
real fighter that look pretty legit it's
real that's a real guy that first one
that first one is questionable the next
two were great it was a questionable are
the same for though I meant for my first
one a little questionable to me if you
watch the whole thing play out and slow
motion what happens is you see a left
hook I was anything for if you see a
stumble and Floyd moves in and their
legs tangle up a little bit and then
Floyd hit someone the right hand when
he's on his way down boy fuck that dude
up